were you a supporter of barack obama
absolutely i still am this was a big
moment in your life when barack won the
presidency yeah it was incredible it was
incredible i went to the inauguration
you did you know oh yeah you know is
that because you were a supporter were
you invited it was more it was more uh
an act of emotion you know because you
know the night of the election you know
my wife and i am crying like going i'm
going to the inauguration you know and
it's a week later she's like are you
serious because we got to start now
getting those tickets right which was
just a you know slippery slope into you
you were so overwhelmed with emotion
first black president who would ever
imagine in our lifetime we would see
this and
you're proud of the country for not
voting racially i didn't know i really
didn't know if we were if we were ready
as a country that if it was going to go
down right until it actually went down i
mean it was an incredible night so you
say to your wife in that moment of
euphoria listen baby we're going to the
inauguration they're going to be there
i'm going to be there
can you get us tickets i'm like can i
get us tickets what are you kidding me
watch all of this was kind of through
comedy central
that show slipping at the end oh yeah
the show is slipping every week and i'm
like you know the first week i was
promised uh vip platinum
ticket package by the time we got there
we had purple tickets
everybody had so what does it mean when
your ratings are slipping and now you
can't get a great seat was it hard for
you were you so far back
washington dc here's what happened i got
a plane ticket which you couldn't get
and then i got a hotel room you know
which which you could not get right and
then the pr chick starts calling going
look there's kind of a problem i'm like
all right you're freaking me out now
because i've spent thousands of dollars
i don't have a ticket she goes all right
okay well uh we're not going to get the
platinum ticket you know
but you can purchase it for 25 000 and i
was like
exactly so i'm like okay what can you do
for
ten thousand then it was five thousand
then it was just like and so we got
these purple tickets purple tips where
did the purple tickets put you he got to
shake hands with the senator yeah 10
feet from my hotel room i mean it was
that the whole thing was a [ __ ]
is it true as it says in your book that
you were sitting behind a tree
i was standing in front of a tree
and that was in front of the jumbotron i
never saw barack obama i never saw the
stage
and i was like god is
telling me something and at one point
i'm like why
i heard it i didn't really see it i
heard it and but then it became this big
it was very moving i mean this woman
next to me was like
you know i lost my family and will you
be my family and i said sure but when
she said i lost my family my instinct
was like
oh my god
they were dead and she says no i lost
them because i lost my wife
there are four million people there so i
said absolutely i will be your family so
i'm hugging her
and it became this emotional moment and
in the middle of hugging her i look down
and there's this other black woman
holding onto her leg and i was like
what are you doing
this is my movie moment she says well i
want to be your family too and i'm like
yeah absolutely true and i was like
really i can't even have this
i have to share it with you